when I was eight or nine you know it
kind of hit me
I kind of realized you know that uh the
hand that had been solved but yes virtue
of the geography Osborne banks that I
only had one shot and one ticket out of
poverty my out of the village and that
ticket was doing well in the exams here
we have exams at eighth grade two people
are getting the boarding school I went
to do the only way I could do that is if
I will be ranked the first kid mother
eighth grade examine my counting so that
I could represent the the I could take
the county's slot this is kind of like
the NBA Draft but now the talent is just
how you're gonna do on a three day exam
as I approached eighth grade my as I
purchased exam it became a really young
age a do-or-die moment right because if
I couldn't be able to go to this
publicly funded government secondary
school my parents couldn't afford to
take me to any other form of secondary
school and if I can't go to second was
holy and the kind of dreams that I can
dream the kind of life I can leave you
know the kind of difference you know
it's a different vibe you know and I am
I do consider myself to be lucky and I
actually and if you ask my parents you
know people ask them do you think like
Tom go and hover is like the best thing
that has ever happened to you do to him
or to you guy and they always say you
know it's Tom getting into high school
right boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are at the Elliott house at Harvard in
beautiful Cambridge Massachusetts we are
now going to be talking about actual
izing Africa's potential we have Tom
Osbourne ako Kumu joining us on the show
thank you so much for having me I'm
pretty excited I'm super excited thank
you thank you for coming on and who
shout out to Julia Shafer again hooking
us together to do this so for those who
don't know Tom's background so tom is
actually his Christian name
oh cool Moo is his tribal name so Akuma
Tom Osborne is a psychology and computer
science student at Harvard University
focused on life outcomes of young people
in sub-saharan Africa in 2014 he
co-founded green char which provides
clean cooking fuel for homes schools and
institutions in Kenya having raised
venture capital and grew the staff to 20
people and have 3,000 clients since then
he is principal investigator of the
Shamir a mental health project at the
laboratory for youth mental health at
Harvard University and consulting with
companies doing business in Africa with
organizations like Safaricom which is
Kenya's largest telecom provider all
right
epic background very young it's very
interesting that this move even from
Kenya to Cambridge which we're going to
talk about and the differences in
culture and kind of what's happening on
a geopolitical level let's start things
off with one of our favorite questions
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world Wow once again thank you so
much for having me and sorry for making
you go through a mouthful bye oh yeah
well that's a really interesting
question I am I'm optimistic about the
direction of the wall you know I think
right now more than ever especially in
the committee's that I come from you
know we are seeing the way technology is
impacting people's lives in terms of
improving access to healthcare in terms
of improving access to quality education
in terms of increasing civic and
political engagement I think if we kind
democratize the world before I mean with
this if we can get 70% of the wall which
has been left behind when it comes to
making decisions about the future
they're all involved in the table if you
can make countries in South Africa the
global south and all I just have to look
at
the dining-table from the window but
also you've going to give them a seat in
the dining table and make them more
important players in determining the
direction of the wall then we can be
able to unlock you know the potential
you know that we have right now you know
because technology is revolutionized
everything and if we do defectively you
know we can't be on a path towards
something great in our life right yeah
what a great analogy for looking at it
just not being at the dining table of
decision-making just that the decisions
are being made by other people for us
yeah versus being as civically engaged
and inspired yeah which is kind of sad
because you know a majority of the
countries in the world majority of
societies are democratic
you know and and the first year
democracies are we should all be in the
dining table but you know the way we
have implemented democracy doesn't leave
to the lady
you know we're sniffing the Roma from
the table but that's as close as we are
to the acute hemorrhoid and so we have
refused global centers of
decision-making telling we some good and
all years we have about 50,000 people
telling 7 billion people how to live you
know and making the decisions for the
the 7 billion people involved yeah
mm-hmm and this is a major difference in
culture in terms of just having complete
freedom over direction of decision of
how I want to behave for what reasons
maybe it's enough for productivity and
economic gain or reason maybe it's more
for just living period just being alive
and just engaging with people in a
playful way so this is although there is
also some crazy benefit of being able to
live parents sick well some of the
capitalistic health care infrastructure
has also helped
our parent or family member live 10 20
30 more years so it's a very strange
conversation we'll bounce very nuanced
and difficult to figure out exactly what
it is which I want to let's get let's
actually dive into that a little bit
more in this in this next bit okay so
the yeah just nuts the way you're
putting it just like tens of thousands
of people making decisions for billions
yes yes
so okay finding yourself near berra
berra berra yeah Mia Berra in Kenya this
isn't a wrong go district on West Kenya
and near Lake Victoria so this is where
you're born and then I want you to speak
about this life in Kenya what is this
like culturally politically economically
yeah yeah you know so if you look at the
map of Kenya in Nairobi with the capital
is right there in the middle if you go
eight hours west towards Lake Victoria
you'll come to know better and that's
how I was born
up and I was born in a really you know
interesting time I was born when Kenya
was as a country you know was going
through what adults will consider
midlife crisis in this country which is
just in his forties approaching it's
fifties never as a country you know
where we are still in a right now
grappling with basic things like what
does it mean to be a canyon right and we
will you know talk about it later but
like one of scramble and petition for
African deed is a made people citizens
of countries for which none of them you
know participated in the decision around
well you know in the decision around
that country being a country in the
first place and you know one of the
things where I came to the US for
example I'm gonna tie to in your berries
people ask me
how do you deal how do you live in such
a diverse society as the US you know
where there's coral this kind of
discrimination going on I am like the
only difference is not everyone but most
people in the US and decided they're
going to be part of this country you
know so in Kenya just to give you a
background we are 42 tribes 42 different
cultures for two different traditions
some of which historically have disliked
each other and then now forced to be a
country to coexist to be Paciorek to you
know love the flag and all this kind of
stuff and so when I was born we had
perhaps one of the most iconic moments
you know you know history as a country
where we interested them to enter the 24
year old
Eros dictatorships of for 24 years Kenya
was an elite leadership bowler men also
is the living conditions were pretty you
know difficult you know the challenges
that I grappled with as a young boy were
primarily around survival games around
waking up carrying food going to school
coming back home seeing everyone is okay
you know thanking cordovan good night
and you know repeating every day you
know my dream when I was 7 years old was
to be a pastor cause you know in my
village does the most respected you know
person was there was a church leader or
the school teacher you know
Buckland thinking they're all for
example be here giving this podcast at
Howard college we will think I was
higher
[Laughter]
some kind of drug you know yeah and what
I do like about my upbringing is I think
I got a grounding what I like to call
the fundamentals fundamentals of
humanity
I think this for a mentors were one
which we we do not appreciate matches in
just life just being able to enjoy
living you know we don't we we take for
granted but I think it's it's a really
great gift to have people you know when
you're when you're growing up and you
don't have you have television to keep
you entertained or you don't go on hikes
over the weekend or summer comes right
you only have your peers you only have
your friends right and so you're so
people become deeply a much more
important role when I was growing up
there are only like friends but also
like social support outlet yeah yeah and
a couple things first crazy on 24 year
dictator leaving around 95 so those 2000
to 2002 he has one that okay okay but I
thought you said it was when you were
born
okay a little better yeah okay okay so
so that was like the viewer positive
remember like one of my first like
channel memories are around the two
thousand two thousand two three period
where we were moving on because was such
a good time of optimism because we were
coming from this long dictatorship yeah
and so then it became a time of more
optimism because it got out of a
dictatorship that wasn't that healthy
for the people of the country yeah okay
and then there you said there's 42
tribes there 42 42 tribes that have
historically also been interesting
relationships between each other yeah
all the four two tribes but some of the
four two tribes
historically you know hospital issue so
like a really good example is I went to
high school next to Nairobi and the high
school arranges a public boarding school
but the way the government and when it
keeps to school is a miracle escapes
from every county and I remember before
I went to school people in my village
telling me be careful of kids from
x-tribe because they eat people for
example or they do XYZ or these people
from stripe can't be trusted because the
extra color crooks or thieves or
something like that right so we have
always with really interesting relations
and always interesting relations you
have to form a nation right but it
becomes hard to do that cause in my
village you speak the law which they
don't speak in 80% of Kenya more I and
yeah so it's it's different ballgame
there yeah seriously
interesting so the boarding school
itself actually had kids from all of
these different tribes dance for you
you kind of got exposed to that in a
sense and kind of did you did you feel
for well these are all just young kids
from around Kenya like there's just it
became kind of normal to interface with
the different ones and see how you're
kind of just all human yeah and I think
those the intention of the school and I
think the school the system did a really
good job if it goes over to three weeks
you know for a few months you know you
you realize all this difference has do
you grown up with our artificial
differences they're not exist
you know we care about the same things
we want some you know dreams often life
right and I think the only and for your
thing is right now not all kids in Kenya
you are able to kind of experience this
kind of environment that's why for
example tribalism is still you know
public you headed into generationally I
think this kind of school and exposing
cage
young age to Davos people truly helps
break the stereotypes and such at such a
formative age also yeah yeah okay couple
quick things one of the things is that I
also coming from a very heavily white
part of South Dakota in the middle of
the United States went to Minneapolis
Minneapolis much more liberal
cosmopolitan melting pot immediately
became exposed to people from Latin
America people from Africa people from
Asia people from yet different parts of
the world Europe and so immediately my
all of those notions of any sort of
bigotry we're just like these are humans
and so it was beautiful having that
moment and then also going to San
Francisco after that again another
moment a more cosmopolitan melting pot
so and that's interesting that you can
even relate that to like 42 tribes in
Kenya as well so you can be viewed that
way okay also you mentioned this really
interesting the fundamentals I thought
that was really cool
we're here it can be as simple as being
distracted by television or any other
one of these distractive and things that
we have versus one of the fundamentals
that you listed is this wake wake up
food and then you you need to figure out
how to feed yourself you need to go to
school you need to when you kind of you
kind of the priest or the for the
teacher is known as the two of the
highest positions amongst you and then
you come back home and you you are
grateful that your family is still there
and that everyone's healthy and and then
you have to learn like you said the
social the social the social aspects
speak up more about that yeah I think
one of the when is going to be one of
the greatest challenges of a life frame
is going to be around sociability I
think you know the internet and
Technology has done a tremendous amount
of great things in the wall in a week we
cannot and we shall art like under
understate the Diwali one importance of
technology Cole advances into should be
encouraged
I think one
one byproduct for college of this rapid
advancements in technology is a way of I
think lost this element of sociability
you know finding joy and happiness in
human human interruption just for the
sake of the human human interaction we
think is a really important part of how
we've evolved as people it's kind of
being lost because now we can go a day
two days three days or even talking to
anyone and we'll be you know perfectly
okay
but because of that I think we develop a
lot of challenges especially Mitel
related challenges you know we people
becoming less sad in some societies for
example you you see new studies coming
out that 30% of people in Japan like
have never been in a relationship and
they're like over 35 years old and I
think we we risk losing the value and
enjoyment of just consuming human human
interactions for the sake of just those
interactions with other interactions
having to lead to say to a specific and
yeah and I think if we can figure out
how to make technology a little bit more
social and and more facilitating all
these interruptions at all the great
idea we have a lot to talk about that
difference between just social
interactions for the sake of just
well-being in life versus needing to get
to some sort of an economic or
productive goal from it
that's it's such an interesting point
now but I want you to give us you know
going from village to the boarding
school oh okay yeah how did how did you
get even into that boarding school first
yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah we know so
when I was eight or nine you know it
kind of hit me
and I kind of realized you know that uh
the hand that had been solved but yes
virtue of the geography I was born mine
that I only had one shot and one taken
out of poverty my out of the village and
that take it was doing well in the exams
here we have exams at eighth grade and
basically two people are getting the
boring so I went to the only way I could
do that is if I will be ranked the first
kid mother earth grade exam in my County
so that I could represent the the I
could take the county's slot this is
kind of like the NBA Draft but now the
talent is just how you're gonna do on a
three day exam and as I approached
eighth grade my as I purchased exam it
became a really young age a do-or-die
moment right because if I couldn't be
able to go to this publicly funded
government secondary school my parents
couldn't afford to take me to any other
form of secondary school and if I can't
go to second was holy and the kind of
dreams that I can dream the kind of life
I can leave you know the kind of
different it's a different vibe you know
and I am I do consider myself to be
lucky and I actually and if you ask my
parents you know people ask them do you
think like Tom Grover is like the best
thing that has ever happened to you do
to you guys and they always say you know
it's Tom getting into high school right
that catalyzed all of the other doors
yeah and it's just imagining the kind of
pressure are such a really young
formative age and the other options
being and so that's you know one of the
things the country inspires what I'm
doing is you know whenever I go back
home you know the kids in my age group
who I grew up with you know who was such
an integral central part of my youthful
experience when coming of age who what I
wouldn't worry who as lucky and you're
seeing the kind of lives that you know
ladies it is it is not only side it is
really sad yeah but also just means that
I kind of longer be able to enjoy like
my friendship and interactions with them
you know as much as I will oh yeah and
yeah and so it is zero zero zero really
unfortunate when I went to the boarding
school
I think boarding school reinforced for
me where I want to get all called
fundamentals and so it was an all-boys
boarding school and we will stay in
school for nine months we had no access
to electronics if you wanted to talk to
your parents write them a letter or
you'd have to organize with your class
teacher to call them and delimit large
like once every two or three weeks so
we're they're cut off from the whole
world and once again um to be able to
you know thrive in this kind of setting
you how to really speller of time being
able to socially
ontology other cajun socially figure out
your way around the school I think one
of the things I read a lot of the school
is we're just really helping now is just
an ability to be able to not be
intimidated in social settings
especially since the care of the us of
realize a lot of my peers Galu likely be
anxious in social environments where
some spotlight of some simple it may be
in them and and some kind of lucky to
have had that experience yeah but also
one thing just before we move on about
the boarding school was it also changed
you know they told you when I was
growing up you just being a priest or a
teacher right but I moved from the
village was completely off grade a
village where when the Sun went down all
our lives you know was closed for night
you know just told stories and went to
bed at 8:00 to 9:00 p.m. I went to
boarding school you know said you know
riding water access to the electricity
computers internet well like the Alumni
were lawyers like scream call judges and
preneur doctors businessmen school had
exchange programs with kids some from
like American colleges it's just like
interaction with his new wall you know
exposed me to a new thing that I didn't
have but also credit a deep in tunnel
battle because every time when I they
will feel like you believe the school I
won't go back home you know it becomes
hard to peacefully reconcile this to all
you know and just you know just live
peacefully that's to us yeah Wow yeah it
the way that you're telling the story is
sinking in very deeply into me and and
hopefully others as well at and for such
a variety of reasons one of them being
that when you find yourself as the young
boy it was eighth grade taking the
three-day exam right yeah when you're
there and you know that that moment is
can it will bifurcate the trajectory of
your life and then the all the other
doors that opened up from going to the
boarding school and continuing to work
really hard and doing everything else in
your life to get to here versus on the
other side of like you described that
when you go back and engage with
socially with the classmates that you
were with up until then that how do you
engage then when what their stimuli that
they've been around versus the ones that
you've been around that the alumni of
the boarding school are lawyers
entrepreneurs doctors businessmen
that that is so much different than
being in a village where it's a priest
and the teacher are the two highlights
and that you have the with the the level
of amount of of dollars per day that you
can earn in those two locations yes it's
different
loneliest economical you know but also
just how you think and view life and how
you you don't fit all your position in
life or - view and your values you know
it's it's it's it's
it's different you know my classmates
almost have for now you know married and
have kids you know cause you know when
you can no longer if you can exceed
academically then maybe succeeding
socially you know by building family is
you know an option on you you can't
blame them for making the decision I'm
just trying to in in their thinking you
get the best out of your life or when
you meet people and socially you know
talking about things like politics of
how who are you going to vote for you
know and if someone will prioritize a
politician who gives them for five
dollars for your vote you know you you
you know you cannot you cannot blame
them and that is where I think most
people go wrong when they talk to the
like Tom why is it that we have spent so
much money International Development you
know trying to create to make people at
the bottom of the pyramid Africa change
their behaviors but they're not or XYZ
but you realize when the system fails
but I'm not just one person but I'm a
jury of the community you know you
cannot blame the individual for putting
their own self-interest in the moment
you can you couldn't blame me for
praising themselves right now and nor
everyone in the future it makes it now
hard you know when you're trying to do
things that are important when you're
trying to address issues around climate
change in health care and financial
sustainability that require you
more future thinking you know it becomes
it becomes like this kind of it's a it's
it's it's it's it's a fashio it's a
vicious cycle it's it's just it's a
cycle it's a trap you know most would
call it a poverty trap and I and I think
it's a real trap and because the way you
think how you feel life you know only
the economic opportunities available to
you it's totally different ballgame you
know and then there are the challenges
the people who are trying to help people
get out of this trap I also don't have a
deep understanding of what it means to
be in the trap well and so they can I'll
be able to develop effective solutions
and if they way I would develop
effective solution they'd also be able
to convince the people with the
development solutions for that is a
defective solution right yeah and it's
it's something I'm grappling with you
know like just the way socially engaging
with my friends and my classmates seeing
where they are in life talking about our
goals and our visions and you know where
our politics and our ideologies
just well the air it is really hard yeah
couple things one of the things is
getting access to Internet electricity
running water the shelter other young
people this alumni network going to this
boarding school this again opened up
your ideas your imagination to see
different ways that you could contribute
to the world your creative potential
versus just whole family or whatever the
other other options are we could spend
hours just on this yeah segment because
I think it's also really important for
like did you have
what was the house like what was the
area of living like for you and your
mother and father and siblings what was
the what was the sleeping like what was
the everyday life like to give us a
taste yeah yeah yeah so I grew up on
sugar cane farm so my family we have
been traditionally sugarcane farmers and
how my home is structured so my
grandfather had three wives and so in
the lure tradition that's my my tribe we
have look we have customs around how the
setup becomes if someone has more than
one one why and so my dad being one of
the youngest kids then his milk heads in
this polygamous
set up it meant that he had to stay
according to code here's the last one
she had to stay with his mom so there is
the the costumed last once on a supposed
to take care of the of the mom and
inherits everything from the mom when
the month passes away so where we grew
up
screw up my grandmother's house three
bedroom three bedroom house and my
parents are two sir how is just about
ten meters from my grandma's house and
yeah and so daily life
she depends you know a lien McCrea like
I had to be a little bit more involved
like the manual labor of working the
farm but as I was approaching eighth
grade my kind of now Hodge to switch
gears to focusing on academics your mom
and dad were both alive and yeah they're
still and both are still and then your
grandpa and grandma from both of their
so my grandfather died in 2000 but my
grandmother was my life she died in 2015
and fortunately but she was alive for
most of my childhood yeah [ __ ] maybe all
of my channel yeah any other two grandpa
and grandma from the other um there's
only one such two grandmas yeah yeah and
then and then did your siblings - so
have three siblings three yeah I have
three siblings my soup was kind of it
was so apart from my immediate family
some max had a family we all stayed like
within the same vicinity so my uncle for
example was only like 20 30 meters from
where we stayed and he had he require if
13 kids and she was just from my like
biological grandma and then they're also
the kids are making two other grandmas
all sleeping around citizen because uh
it was quite a big setup minute in the
farm and so we'd yeah so depending on
what you do so if you're my parents of
farmers every morning they wake up 5:00
a.m. go to the farm every Dean are their
whole life apart from a few times where
they moved to a wine which is a small
town next by and my my dad had a bakery
for a while yeah and it'd be it'd be
also having you and your siblings also
learn about farming and the land yeah
and and you would although you would
then go through cycles of of farming on
the land harvesting the crop selling the
crop to those that are coming to buy the
sugarcane and you would follow us a
cycle yeah yeah and so for example if so
so if if I cooled into a cow did not be
I'd be running the farm
I'd be like they'll be like my primary
vocation right now what are your three
siblings yeah so my family has been you
know just given the life trajectories of
most people in you know really we bring
you know quite like my elder brother
Jane the the military for a while and I
was really interesting sorry our honor
like tell my story on his behalf
but for him you know his take arose
joining the the military not because of
an overt love video for the country but
you know it was one of the only ways he
could get out of the village and my
sister also followed a similar out you
know she didn't get as like as it was
academically and joined up we have the
Prison Service
so she walks in the kind of prison
system yeah my manga brother is just
creating for my school I think he'll be
at least going to the local universities
in Kenya yeah all of the siblings are
left the village yeah yeah Wow yeah so
everyone moved on to life trajectories
that were outside of farming in a rural
area
okay so exposure to Internet and the
young minds in the boarding school and
how did you pick up your interest there
how did you even get Oh Harvard you know
how did yeah
so actually have what happened to me a
little later in my my like surge
actually it wasn't something that I hide
in my mind when I was in high school you
know the first thing that happened in
high school was by suing the
communication system by sophomore year
of high school you kind of have to know
your path know so it's like locking set
and so in my high school we had four
careers
so you either a doctor an engineer a
lawyer or your loser
so they call it and so but I know
freshman year the careers department
worse artist you know we're scientist
all right yeah so unfortunately those in
the business person yeah yeah those
meaning that those into those interested
back in the ballgame so I was in the law
I was I was assigned to be alive because
for two things I could talk and I also
did was a bit better English than
chemistry
it was hard something yeah so they
decided a so you're going to be away and
as a sophomore was like why shield why
should I be taken from the village
exposed to always well you know
especially at a time where young people
in other parts of the world were doing
crazy things this is a time where like
the tech entrepreneurs in the Silicon
Valley had were revolutionizing didn't
have ball game and the Sun has
inspiration all in kids in America but
all over the world you know was a time
well you know young artists like Justin
Bieber going viral and or really young
still in school you know the people who
we correlate with and here I was shown
this whole world and told that I had to
be a lawyer is because I talk a lot and
I did well in English composition and so
I felt really frustrated by the system
and I think it was so many where I
realized that the system that I had
found myself in wasn't going to work for
me yeah and a part time as I was
figuring this out the first time it's a
really common poem here in the US for
the first time I read Robert Frost the
path not taken mm-hmm and when I read it
it just crystallized who had been
thinking that um if I was going to be
happy and successful was to do high
heart to create my own path yeah and
I figure the best way to clear my own
path was do you think about what is
important to me what I care about you
know things that I will happily Co a lot
of time and resources to doing and the
first thing that came to mind was just
the living standards in my village you
know you know I could be a lawyer and in
fact I was like I'd managed to because
her marriage to law school in still in
high school in Kenya today canons like
best law school and I could've gone back
path I realized that I was like how I I
might be remember how I rationalized it
was you know I have been one of very few
lucky people in my community you know
who was calling the chance and the
opportunity to be able to see our
different well and explore different
possibilities I could either think about
it selfishly and be like I deserve ace
I've worked hard you Amy you leave a
great financially viable life and joined
the echelons of you know canyons like
establish mine or something like that or
I could find ways to give ya the
community of the people are cared about
with also what I call an opportunity to
to fight you know like it's not that
which did you know it's not that we lack
an innovation or creativity that the
saying is true that you know talent is
universal our opportunities are not
right and
I think it's pretty sad that most dreams
are shattered not because of a lack of
talent you know because of a lack of
hard work but just a lack of
opportunities yeah
and when I realized towards one breaks
the other in sophomore year you know my
mom had developed this respiratory tract
infection primarily as a result of just
cooking for us and making food for us
and not because of any like personal
negligence on on a side not because of
any like life choices that she had meant
to engage in activities that made her
develop this infection he was really
sobering moment you know I asked myself
why did I have to work really hard why
did I have to leave my village and quote
unquote care and education if I could
help my mom you know like why was I why
was I why why why why do all this if you
can't you know have a profound impact in
the lives of people who mean something
to you and so that was why virgin air of
today working on its various different
projects I know where and then will lead
a weak erection it will tack ie knife
was going to be successful or not you
know if I fail and go back to the
village or wherever come but you know I
had this early it's just this drive and
my
deep personal connection to the problems
that I was thinking about I think spod
that drive yeah you being able to
recognize that you who got blessed with
being able to realize actualize your
opportunities and then want to help
those that don't have those
opportunities is a critical moment of
reflection in life because we can so
often do what you said of saying that
hey I got mine but to be able to say
that we stand on the shoulders of giants
that we have this unity that we need to
have a harmony together and that one of
the ways that I can give after I've been
blessed is to help open up those doors
of opportunity for other people and I
love that a lot about you and there's
also this moment of realization for you
that why is it that the numbers are
staggering
that 80% of Kenyan households use
charcoal for cooking so that your mom
being diagnosed with this lung diseases
infection that this happens four point
three million die every year from the
indoor cooking smoke so these are
preventable deaths these are and that
your mind is think how do we prevent
this how do we upgrade the code from old
cooking code to new code yeah it's
really even among sobering if cancer
what if the solutions are the prevention
of these problems exist you know
and there is one of the greatest
challenges that I still cannot resolve
you know we will we spend a lot of time
on Cringer figuring out the nitty gritty
of trying to make a solution which is
great but still not perfect work yet
create clean solutions
they're like solutions you like people
for example in the u.s. don't die when
they're cooking yes right high income
people don't die when they're cooking
right the will for solving this problem
has already been invented
right but now we have to reinvent and
create a new will you know just because
of the way you know the structure and
saria's and you know just to piggyback
on or you say you know it's sad I think
in our recent history as as humans we've
kind of forgotten that we know we're
here you know cut see we really here the
real box of Gans you know and our
society just to be able to survive and
evolve to be in a position where we can
now build this convivial building you
know we had people who would figure out
basic things like survival and they did
not monetize so much or pardon them you
know fire there is no monetize or
parented you know even the original will
they didn't create a man killed man
economy out of it you know
well origin are yeah and now we are in
the richest time that we've ever been in
the world
booyah also in the most equal that we
have ever been at the same time and so
yeah so it's it's clean cooking is
really special developing well you know
four point three million deaths annually
mainly women because the Muslim
societies women have to be the ones who
bear the burden of
taking Kayla family and this is from
using either wood or charcoal yeah would
best feel wood based fuels in indoors
too so that it's not like their
circulation studies manage because
because it is you know indoors right you
know because there is some I mean you
know it's like especially things like
cooking is like some element of privacy
and or your family privates of people
want to hover around like where they
cook and what they eat and so there is
not like most cooking making most part
of all it is primarily done in dot and
it is really you know unfortunate the
way in this we're still here and it was
just four hundred isn't a lot of like
resources and time and commitment that
is being put to touch housing this
problem well and we we were we were
doing as we were making alternative
cooking fuel from sugarcane waste and
this is your company green chair char
yeah I'm so those three reasons are
inspired that thinking so first of all
just the realities of the economic
condition right it is easy for like an
easy solution will be that's getting
everyone hooked to maybe the great
that'll scare everyone cook like clean
glass cookers right but that is because
of economic system outside the reach of
those they can non-starter
right and then the thing is now much to
innovate around very in federal cost but
in the problem and innovating around
course is you have to make heard of
sacrifices on quality and utility right
because if I was designing I phone the
old Costner
dollars like I can put sterile LCD
screens on the display
but if Mao's designing an iPhone though
cost $30 you know I'm limited in the
amount of thing that I could've put
herself to make lot of compromises and
sacrifice a lot of like quality and
utility just for food I'd say and so
that's why reusing sugarcane waste and
I'm also making sure that the fuel we
developed was as close to existing
charcoal I was important because people
really have stoves that are using
charcoal time most farmers wouldn't be
able to afford the investment of buying
a new tool for cooking so we kind of
watch to meet them where they are and so
we consider the fool away developing as
korokoro bridge into the future ya know
we we we don't think that creature feel
is how people in low-income communities
and while she'll be cooking while people
have parts water enjoying really high
living standards but we we think that
for now or we figure out how to my
colleague distributors horses just give
you people you should be using the tons
of women carrying respiratory tract
infections potentially giving people who
really need economic savings you know
limiting the environmental impact of
deforestation for you it's 125,000 acres
yeah trees lost each year to make
charcoal yeah so kinda we have a crisis
cause of forest cover is now I think
under 3% of of the entire country and it
used to be about 23% like 4050 years ago
yeah and so yes let's touch that was
there we were walking over and there was
a great experience who of course was
really
because you know one of the challenges
we faced was fuel was really cheap -
about 30 cents per kilogram and so 30
times would be enough fuel for one or
two days for most families and how do
you scale up a business where it's a
customer they value great from customer
from business perspective only 30 cents
and imagine they have there is under
three cent right in the alternative is
almost free yeah it's free or almost
free almost free
and then to get up to get some green
char is 30 cents a kilogramme yeah and
most humbly living on $2 of that right
so to put 1/6 or 1/7 over their income
into cooking yeah phew yeah yeah yeah
and so we thought initially that we
could make people see the value of the
field for my health or an environmental
perspective and the feedback regardless
you would be like yes you know I love
the environment you know I own a citrus
cart
you know I potentially don't want to get
sick in the future but you know I have
school fees I have health care expenses
I have living expenses I have $2.00 I'm
so so you have to make if you're making
an economic argument you're gonna have a
lot of trouble convincing me to do that
and from another business perspective
you're also pointing out that you making
a 3-cent profits you make it for 27
years old 30 cents a 30 cent profit to
make yeah the dollar you have to sell 30
of these 33 of these to make a dollar
and then furthermore is trying to you're
putting this in comparison to something
like
like let's say a Tesla like an
automobile that cost $40,000 for someone
to purchase and maybe it only cost them
$20,000 to manufacture so they make a
$20,000 yeah margin this is much is so
yes so so to figure out what the best
solution is to a problem like this given
the parameters like you described
earlier can't just go and get gas line
running to natural gas stove yeah so to
be able to focus on going and enabling
the opportunities and decreasing some of
the health issues like that and you you
had you actually ended up going forth
and doing innovate Kenya than New York
City social entrepreneurship competition
for seed funding to get this going yeah
yeah I think when I was in there were
two elements and it's kind of
unfortunate of these two elements could
not be reconciled and so the first
element is articulating division you
know for the organization articulating
the financial and articulating a plan or
a path towards profitability and when
you're doing that you know doing that
with yo and customer right the people
who are writing the checks is you've
mentioned some of them are in New York
they've never cooked a single day with
any sort of cold let alone drink alcohol
I mean the lives are really removed from
the problem but to solve the problem you
need you need the money right and so
it's something called talking the talk
I'm sure we would get into the dough I
just have a conversation you have to
talk the talk
I often this talk is really different
from what you know can walk on the
ground right and so when I was meeting
investors I'd present
apply and I'll be like
okay so we need $20,000 to be able to
set up docking facility and we think we
can be able to get like $500,000 in
revenue from this and this is a
financial model this is our distribution
plan you know just making sure you take
all these boxes that people take you
seriously and trust you their money but
when you go back to the ground you like
I have a three cent margin how am I
gonna make $500 a three-second right
[Laughter]
some things we just have to admit are
not venture back able this is not a
venture capital thing this is a
philanthropy thing ideally ideally it is
a philanthropy thing right with with
what you describe though it's a model
for you know which equipment you need
you know who you need to hire you know
how to get to more people maybe you need
to just drastically subsidize them get
all the way to free as the alternative
yeah that way your 30 cents for a
kilogram is nothing for the modern
economies of the world yeah so to be
able to subsidize that to save lives
around the world as from a philanthropic
perspective is we just need to be able
to do that better but there's a big
disconnect yeah yeah yeah and there's
something else about social capital
entrepreneurship time yeah yeah I get to
- yeah yeah yeah and it's really
unfortunate even though the week though
we can't be able to get supporting for
this and especially for me and that will
eventually be one of the reasons why and
upcoming Howard is still when I come to
New York and I mean I retired hedge-fund
manager from credit card
I asked him for money he still sees a
90-mile
kid with the weird accent from some
random village in Africa that he's never
heard of right
even if I have an articulate plan I have
no experience doing this I am able to
pull it I don't come from a region or an
area that is renowned for its
intrapreneurship intrapreneurial of HTS
there are no quirk or success stories of
people of my background who have been
able to pull off this kind of dreams and
so those two experiences so that and
just the reality market made me realize
that I had great dreams but I was also
extremely naive you know I thought that
all I needed was to have a good product
work hard and things work out but I
realized I am up realizing but also
really young age but unfortunately in
the world today it still they did that
anyone from anywhere you know can work
hard and access resources and be
successful is great breaks of fantasy
you know I realized that I had a glass
ceiling all the people who are giving me
money we're not giving me money because
I believed in my idea or a thing to do
but sometimes because of selfish reasons
where they were I have felt sympathy
towards me or they having in the
portfolio that hey I am supporting this
kid from Africa makes them look good in
whatever social or River cycles that
that that that they are they are a right
and locally working on the ground Oriel
I said how like I couldn't blame people
were like really like we're doing but
hey you know we're gonna buy his license
just can't do it right so I was in a
position well terms of raising money and
getting capital I kind of at reach the
ceiling in terms of walking love queries
to get the buying the just enough ways
to you know buying behind like part in
the bulk moral support kind of way even
though you couldn't get it from the
villagers the institutions the school's
the factories they could transition away
they could pay the 30 cents a kilogramme
yeah they're cool you know but also
coolant causes primarily I was still you
know for example this is one of the most
sobering experiences for me when I was
at Cringer is the we have arrays I think
maybe I'm it's a multinational called
but I it's a shoe company and they have
like large shoe factories in Kenya and
for some reason we use firewood within
in the production facility and I had
been corresponding with the head of
sales and CEO use trying to see if we
could be able to sign them up to buy our
products and they made it like quite a
lot of they needed about like three
times a week which if was a delivery
called close like would have given us
quite a good revenue boost but when I
went to meet the head of sales and the
CEO to collect impasse through
negotiations so to like pure their
forests and fifteens
and Lulu me underlined
you young man you're 19 year all you
want us to give you and you know you
want us to give you a 210 a week
contract for a much part of our
production system unfortunately yeah
while we think your proposal is strong
we just can't trust you cause yeah yeah
because you have no real-life
credentials that can show that you are
able to to help do this yeah and so
really you know it's kind of really you
change that paradigm young people need
to be given those opportunities when
they just need to come with you and see
oh look look at the production they can
make two tons a week okay great
we they can make it happen let's give
them a shot that type of a thing so that
we can get more young people to have
these opportunities yeah well we also
will eventually need you know parts of
the world trailblazers
we need one or two or three like young
people who see them play and yeah yeah
so that other young people can see that
yeah yeah I also all people can see
there is I can see and so like yeah
changes the narrative a little bit yes
yeah so in 2015
towards 2016 I kind of realized that you
and I I realized it was going to take a
really long time for green tea the
current administration wants to be I
realize that perhaps hired pushed the
needle as much as I could you know I can
work three years straight since 2013
courage to 20 people we had like 3,000
homes to bang on products great some
venture funding but I school in Cresco
and figure out how to scale and make the
organization profitable
and and just so people know there's
other variables like the fact that for
some reason al-shabaab is somehow in
control of the charcoal cartel and that
that exists that these variables in a
different part of the world add
complexity yeah yeah it's that a you
know you know I don't want thing that of
realizes might vary in the u.s. is I
think there's opportunity for a fair
competition of ideas in the market yes
this is going to be like a lot of
pushback from the establishment but I
think over time like good products and
good ideas win against market forces but
in other parts of the world it's not
that you know straight Ford's okay hit
us with the what what what happened from
green chart a to Harvard hit us with
that but from when I started it or from
like that yes because because you you
took us through the boarding school you
took us through green char and then you
we didn't we didn't make we didn't get
to hit the real transition to Cambridge
oh okay yeah what that was even like you
know going through the process of yeah
common app and yeah yeah and all that
stuff yeah yeah yeah so absolutely it's
it's really interesting and kind of
non-traditional approach Heights as I
was telling he like in 2015 I kind of
realized that I was coming to like the
end of my time on Granger but the
adamant my time being like logistical in
operationally and day-to-day you know in
charge of green zone you know like when
you are 1920 yeah and you have like 20
people who every day is about 38
reporting to you you know and that's
likely likely who you know like there
are families and responsibilities
and it's really exciting which is also
really stressful you know cause you know
at the end of the month every month you
have to balance you know balance book
make sure everyone gets paid monkey all
the booze get paid like everyone is
happy then after that you're free deal
with you know sponsors and investor then
all the kind of stuff and I realized
three things I realized one I had not
allowed myself an opportunity to
experience personal growth and really
realizing and discover who I was you
know I had to grow up really quickly you
know I had to tackle our
responsibilities really quickly of our
to be independent my life like really
quickly and I'm really lucky in
hindsight of hard those experiences but
I hadn't like taken time to just just
time you just think about Tom for
example those one thing the second thing
is I knew and he needed a break
posting where I like I didn't know what
I wanted to do immediately a meals gonna
still be involved like fundraising and
totally the shape and I kind of stopped
but that doesn't you know that doesn't
tech 40 hours a week you know and so I
kind of need a figure I was gonna do but
I didn't yeah um effectively know what
was that I was going to do and had I met
this guy called David Sanger who really
resonated with and I really connected to
she was a kid from Sierra Leone who had
grown up through the wall and surely on
was a really impactful life story some
of his family make their lips were limbs
were chopped off during the war
and somehow he came to Harvard and when
here for his undergrad and I went to MIT
for his ph.d and I think he was
developing like on facial prosthetics
for his ph.d and it was also one of the
you've been involved as one of the
cofounders of innovate Canyon it's just
kind of hard Miriam and the miner I
ain't tried with him um I guess so how I
call it doubt David walked the room if
that's I call it I travelled him a few
times and just so how he will be able to
go into like meetings in New York who
like the Rockefeller Foundation and
little mouse information and you know
that writing like a thousand dollar
checks eight hundred thousand dollar
checks right and he will do this in a
really effective way and he was really
effectively able to only actually one CD
but also gather the resources to achieve
we wanted to do in a way that Australia
really inspired me and release for the
first time in my life I kind of had this
quote unquote role model or Idol who I
called model my path around and and
David we also quite a well connected
within the Harvard community and within
the Stanford community also
and so in around much
February 2016 I remember specifically my
god to offers to wanna come to Harvard
and come go to Stanford which is kind of
really interesting because I didn't go
through like in the traditional you know
application process you know for you
know coming to college that might most
of my peers and colleague have and so I
kind of watch to see well well do and so
I never shared with both schools to see
you know which school will give me the
best offer and well like both gave me
really good offers but I think Howard
kind of went out of its way to show that
they really wanted me to come here and
so that's how it's how I ended up in in
camera yeah so David is a huge influence
that you saw him in his in his action
and that you saw him as a role model in
that sense and that you see he also had
come out and went he said MIT and he
came 12 odd for his I'm Laura Reardon
and MIT and so it turned into that see
it be it as well that you
we need more examples like that in order
for us to be able to pursue are also are
our Jews in that sense and then also
that there's a when when you're going
through this process of getting this
this this it's an unconventional style
of of application process and acceptance
so what was the unconventional aspect to
it you know like traditionally you know
you have to well I mean I may not be an
expert in this
could I have like a good experience with
it but I think traditionally you know
people have to do like a few of the
tasks you know do like a more thorough
application thing but in my case where I
just had to do it is to sand in just
like like just to mail in like my high
school transcript and I also got David
wrote them a letter
that's you know and he also had I think
one thing David harder I also really
farmer able is he for some reason has
his ability to get influential important
people involved to listen to him and you
know to trust his opinion I am really
lucky that he saw something in me and
you know kind of helped me yeah kind of
helped me kind of notch me towards
actually because I I at that time was
really as I mentioned really against the
system and schools like Harvard and
Stanford and similar schools were part
of the system that I uh I was against
and so I think out of my own free
volition I would have probably thought
my time will be best served in different
places but I think what David told me is
you you have all these dreams all these
visions and you want to actually you
know you will have what you will stand
for and you go to these schools you can
hear much you might be better to make
more effective are being able to achieve
you know the the the the goals that you
wanted to do and when I come to Canberra
you know August 2016 heroes
two things up and so those the first
time in like three years I've been in a
space where no one knew me so you know
part of bigger and purloin can switch to
the canyons really small countries of
Hawaii I kind of hide like this kind of
name recognition saturated yeah and also
being like one of the only a key on
intrapreneurs who I'll accept raise
money and I was like building something
yeah
those like some like tension scrutiny
that came and this was your second trip
New York was what year as well kill
knows my Todd tree third trip
okay and you'd what tenth took two trips
to New York yeah two trips to New York
um so I also took a trip to Seattle and
San Francisco and Seattle in San
Francisco you yeah
and so curious as as you talked about
yes coming in and nobody knowing you and
kind of restarting fresh in a sense
simultaneously seeing a country like
developed an area that's developed like
Cambridge versus a village and a and
that's capital like Nairobi as well just
the differences in culture differences
in people the difference all of that
stuff as well
combined together give us a taste of
that yeah so you know camping is really
different from Nairobi which is really
you know a different film like the
village grew up you know so for example
in easily Jeanine everyone who you
interact with on a daily basis they near
you the knew your parents knew your
sisters they knew your family wherever
traditional history people went to the
same charge before in the same school
yeah so it's kind of like a like
everything's a life is static but like
life revolves around the same people but
any Robbie is kind of the opposite
spectrum six million people really full
of life you know
really chaotic city also right and so I
think staying it over three years on
high school I developed Michael a six
and sorry
you know because we never you say you
you you either thrive where you get
eaten in a theory and so to try you how
to develop this kind of a sixth sense
obvious being able to I come like small
ways and big way small ways you think
being able to never get traffic quite no
one really cares but traffic rules like
you know being able to deal with the
cops when all of them want you to bribe
them very few haven't done anything
wrong right being like a young person
who people think is a quote unquote
successful entrepreneur it's being able
to deal with the expectations of that
calm wind and so I normally whenever go
back to Nairobi normally feel like alive
you know just because of all these and
we're mindful stimuli that something I
normally don't have when I'm in Canberra
I think temperatures are like most
American cities of Libra organized like
less chaotic yeah things aren't I'm you
know people follow their calendars don't
show up late for you know for meetings
and just cuz I'm not used to that you
know I places like I'm not excited by
the day-to-day calendar of like daily
activities of life whereas in a row be
like I kind of wake up knowing that
there's going to be something actually
something I didn't plan that's going up
and so I look forward to figuring out
what I say that I didn't plan for that
looks to happen the thing is just the
element of sociability director
mentioned to you earlier
I mean if it's a function of the city of
Cambridge or just broad American Society
but everything is a means to some and
conversation the remains some and social
interruptions are a means to some and we
don't have the joy of interacting with
humans just for damping humans which is
something that I found mostly in Italy
but also in in Nairobi
you know just the ability to walk on the
street me restrain Ian talk to them for
four minutes and none of you being
considered a weirdo Sally remains here
but I think of Grovyle as a passion in
Cambria I think the nature of the city
and the nature of the culture here
because people spend a lot of time
personally and individually you really
get to explore yourself in more intimate
ways than you would in a more socially
vibrant more socially dynamic society
way to have as much time to focus on the
past or where life where like even
focusing on the person is problematic
because you trained to the person is
part of the society not an individual
entity you crazy we're talking about
before we went on the show that the when
you move to a place like Cambridge that
the devices these things that are we use
to access all of not all the knowledge
that civilization knows that that these
are so complicated in the supply chain
and in the development and the user
experience and all that type of stuff
that these are not ubiquitous in the
village in Kenya these are not
ubiquitous around the world yet there's
only a couple billion of them around the
world out of the eight billion humans
and further is that you know the other
thing that's really important to
understand is that you come to a place
like Cambridge you're automatically
surrounding yourself with some of the
most
brilliant people that the most powerful
nodes in terms of influence power
intelligence across their fields as well
so there are these interesting
differences between this okay let's hit
on the maximizing life outcomes of young
people in sub-saharan Africa it's a
project that you're currently working on
called Shamir a mental health project
okay so teach us about this great yes
just as I rightfully mentioned you know
most of these tools you know they're are
so common and so I can put on in you
know life specially in the Western world
that are fortunately not as prevalent as
miners as utilize the other parts of the
wallet right and so as a result in some
of the opportunities there people have
access to here you know for example you
have these vibrant show you know young
people working from who may have similar
ideas similar visions can't be able to
realize and occupy them in a similar way
acts I think the challenge biggest
challenge in my generation and whether
I'm just being like sub-saharan African
generation is going to be that we have a
really youthful population
I think the mean age is 18 years old in
the continent it is projected this young
population is going to double by 2050
but then the system has not been built
to effectively provide this beautiful
population where the porcinis are they
needed to succeed in the 21st century
and so we are kind of at a crossroads
where we either have this vibrant
dynamic energetic youthful population
that's about to explode and
unleashed so much potential that can
change the trajectory of so many
people's life on so many things in the
world right or we are starting just
before humanitarian crisis of tons and
tons of young youthful people who have
given up causing have enough
opportunities to to succeed and I
personally think that there will be
maybe the problem that I spend most of
my life thinking about and trying to
figure out but it's also really big and
broad problem and salute tougher
effectively you have to kind of like
segment it into smaller you know
segments that you can tackle one by r
and right now mainly focusing on the
academic and medical outcomes of young
people especially at our sentencing
schools and why I think this is
important because most of life outcomes
are determined during this really
formative age so it's kind of like your
life is set at a really young age like
what happened to you and yeah yeah and
just because of this is also more
pressure to you know because most things
I you most of your decisions are at time
when you still have a good grasp of all
this make or break determines your your
future and there's also just hardships
life hardships and similar things and so
I think the tall on many young kids male
half is high yes because of this
increase this is really tremendous
pressure a really young a
but still there is limited or no work
being done to kind of address this issue
and so that's why I think my house is
really important for young free Allen
dollar signs but then you were you think
we welcome to yell at all sense
especially in Kenya and similar
countries because most of their future
outcomes also are tied to the present
academic outcomes would have a solution
you developed for any problem has to go
hand in hand with improving academic
outcomes because that is the most
effective way that you'll get buy-in
from schools buy-in from parents buying
from when the kids themselves right if
they can see tangible benefits in there
and in the canary performance so we
train only the process of traveling a
few positive psychology based
interventions that we think can help
kids realize just how much they can
improve and change with vane without
depending on our external forces and
whereas there may be in the measurement
they may have been soft difficult hands
in life where they still have the
ability and the the potential to take
control of their futures and hopefully
we hope to give them some tools that
they cannot do that to kids to do that
yeah which interventions so right now
amiri is more than 20 we're developing
successful Hillyard for thrive and so
the idea is the really simple tools in
in the Western tradition they call him
tools in psychology but I just think the
general life tools that we have
advantage of but you know can have
profound impacts on our life so for
example
gratitude yeah and especially in an
environment where on pepper the appears
below
for if you can teach and provide kids
with the tools that can allow them to
feel more grateful for their lives if
you can't walk with kids mind their
peers and their schools to develop
values and value systems that are
important to them and figure out a way
you know that they can leave up their
values in this society I would leave
their schools and within there are can
you give them an opportunity to be able
to kind of replenish or rebuild energy
resources I mean to call difficult life
circumstances but also more protocols
kids and like financial literacy
you know sociability skills you know
like how do you furtively interact with
people in social settings and what I'm
excited about this cause is a low-cost
solutions and can be done by
undeliverable local people within the
communities don't require any extreme
expertise to be able to effectively do I
if you're delivering the interventions
through local community leaders that
work with the youth especially walk with
local teenagers work with high school
graduates and so we train high school
graduates to go back to high schools
okay and definitely for this
intervention great yeah yeah okay okay
we're I'm excited to follow up on that
all right so will will will will revisit
some of these other questions that we
have about the geopolitical side of
what's been happening in Africa in the
last in the last especially decade we
saw initial Scramble for Africa where it
looks like we potentially will have
another one and to be able to treat that
like we're helping people versus just
trying to exploit resources and gain
capital and land this is a very delicate
balance yeah they miss a lot of things
why we're seeing
unquote second version of the Scramble
for Africa you know we are gonna have
like the largest are arable land into
time where populations are increasing
and we have figure out new ways to feed
the human population the tech industry
of Amir specifically has been built on
the back of Congo which is one of the
poorest countries in the world we have
trillion dollar companies built of
titanium and silicon with your mind in
the Congo where the average incomes for
one dollar a day and we have a sale
youthful vibrant population range full
of people means accessible labour force
as we've been saying for example China
is becoming increasingly important in in
Africa because they're saying so many
deals they're doing so many
infrastructure projects and when Chinese
government is taking advantage
specifically of what they understand is
that the average person in in the
African country doesn't care as much
about some of these trade rules so that
that they're dealing with and
politicians and government leaders are
able to get away with corruption get
away with subpar deals and while you
know a popular pushback is that unlike
the west where we have a lot of Western
governments or Western companies which
pretends to have a humanitarian cause
and pretends to be doing something for
the world but have ulterior motives this
is the China you know upfront what you
or you're dealing with but I think an
important thing that we ever think about
is content and especially as young
people in the
continent who very soon will be the most
important demographic in terms of
determining who the leadership is yes we
need to put leaders who are able to and
are going to fight to be able to
negotiate from position at least of
equality but potentially position of
power but ideally a position of equality
by the worst case right because it is
not a bad thing to have deals with China
and with the Netherlands and reversal in
Russia it is nobody we are increasingly
global going on that yeah and there's
more to on by remaining so but we have
to make sure that the kind of arguments
you carrying are not exploitative yeah
that the multi thousands of years of
culture that has developed on those
lands does not just come in one
generation or two generations and just
exploited and yeah you know grab like a
game of Monopoly all right and on the
way out were kind of in a crazy era of
leveraging the technological tools it's
exponential technology is happening what
is a skill that you recommend young
people children to know as we move into
this age I think sociability I think one
more most of the things we do now and
require technical skills far will be
done via technology and you know a
generation the tempos might tire and the
most important skill may be just our
ability to effectively interact with
other human beings yeah and yeah cuz I
think ten years ago maybe lining out
record will be the skills but I think if
quite a lot of people who no no no
and technology is improving really
rapidly to the extent where most of this
of Cleary's will be details in manchuria
so yeah what didn't what a crazy thing a
couple decades of using technology can
obsolete social skills to the point
where they become so much in demand what
a insane thing to consider yeah it's a
good one and last two questions are we
in a simulation I don't think so if you
love God and quit actually the end of
the simulation yeah I would want to have
a one and honor there grind up to take
over simulation yeah it's not over
though yeah but potentially a fantastic
ending especially with that
actualization like we say of the young
people around the world yeah yeah and
last question what's the most beautiful
thing in the world dad but uh stuff on
oh I'd say life you know I think their
life we can't be able to enjoy any of
the other beautiful things in the world
so you know it should be the most
beautiful just living and living yeah
okay so much beautiful stuff unpacked in
this episode tom cool mood thank you so
much for joining us on the show no
worries thanks for coming to Ken Breanna
spreading fuzz we just making this
happen I loved it I loved every single
minute of it there was such an honor and
a pleasure we learned so much a greatly
appreciate everyone for tuning in
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode also go
and check out Tom will kumo links below
as well also do share the content like
this share conversations about
actualizing Africa all of these
different things we talked about with
your friends your families your
co-workers online on social media get
talking about this type of content and
support the organizations the
entrepreneurs the artists around the
world that you believe in sports
simulation our links are below let us
keep doing cool things like coming out
to Cambridge for interviews and go and
build the future everyone man
your dreams into the world thank you so
much for tuning in and we will see you
soon peace
cry specifically the just getting behind
the eyes of what it was like you know
being in issues in his village and
having the moment of the bifurcation and
life trajectory and boom boom boom a
couple more open doors with hard work
and what the [ __ ] you're in Cambridge at
[ __ ] Harvard and and now the stimuli
that he's taken in to be able to go back
and you know both yeah create
opportunities of course but also just
the fact that his brain cannot
communicate with the villagers brains
anymore